incendie dans le sud de la france le
mistral ne facilite pas la tâche des
pompiers plusieurs centaines d'hectares
sont partis en fumée dans les
bouches-du-rhône près de
lançon-de-provence des maisons et des
lotissements été évacués en corse le feu
progresse 1500 hectares ravagés premiers
grands départs dans les gares pour les
juillettistes avec plus d'un million de
voyageurs attendus ce week-end 2500
train dont plus d'un millier de tgv
sur les routes une journée classée
orange le dispositif du médecin traitant
est entrée en vigueur depuis ce matin
pour les malades il faut donc passer par
le généraliste avant de consulter si
besoin un spécialiste une journée de
rodage le tour de france commence demain
et jan ullrich a été victime pendant
l'entraînement d'un accident plus de
peur que de mal
sa seule obsession battre l'américain
lance amstrong et puis le festival de
danse de montpellier le chorégraphe
presse locale
pour sa nouvelle création a choisi de
dépoussiérer à classique et de la
musique
les quatre saisons de vivaldi madame
monsieur bonsoir commençons ce journal
parlé premier gros incendie de l'été
d'abord près de lançon de provence les
flammes poussées par un vent violent ont
déjà détruit plus de 600 hectares de
pinède et de garrigue l'autoroute a7 a
été fermé quelques heures en milieu de
journée
coupure également sur l'a8 à l'heure
qu'il est l'incendié serait fixé nous
disent les pompiers mais pas état ils
ont bataillé toute la journée à pied
d'oeuvre venus en renfort de plusieurs
régions quelques centaines de soldats du
feu appuyée par des bombardiers d'eau l'
incendie serait probablement d'origine
criminelle
gers inutile mortier qui benoît jourdain
les flammes lèchent les maisons 510 est
venu buter sur le haut du village de
qunu avec moi
ça gagne et d'un coup je n'étais pas
inquiète jusqu'à maintenant la main
devant les flammes autour de ma maison
c'est vraiment j'ai juste la pointe
extrême du président bénévole ou
pompiers chacun avec ses moyens senti
d'arrêter les flammes qui grignotent les
jardins avec des rafales de vent à 100
km heure les pompiers ont eu à peine le
temps de dérouler les tuyaux on est
arrivés le feu est en train d'arriver
très fort sur la maison donc on a fait
deux de suite une protection de la vida
et là on procède à la phase de noyage
pour après noyés dans la fumée le
lotissement est entre les mains des
pompiers les résidences fui 120 maisons
ont été évacuées au total encore my
j'espère que les jeunes aient marre
qu'il est malade c'est plutôt par tous
comme une horreur voilà l'horreur les
habitants observent de loin plus bas
dans le village inquiète vraiment parce
que pour l'instant on voit pas de
pompiers on voit personne donc on sait
pas si on peut plus que de nos maisons à
toute allure
le feu a parcouru ce 10 km en trois
heures et demie aucune victime aucun
dégât à déplorer mais 500 hectares de
végétation sont partis en fumée
donc c'est une origine manifestement
suspecte puisqu'elle est issue de deux
foyers très proche allumée en bordure
jeudi à lui mais parce que c'est presque
certain allumé en bordure de la
départementale 17 en fin d'après midi le
feu était fixé mais pas éteint 200
pompiers devraient poursuivre le travail
toute la nuit
dans le var maintenant ce sont deux
foyers distincts qui se développe
attisées par le mistral qui continuent
de souffler entre draguignan et saint
tropez une centaine d'hectares a déjà
été avalés par les flammes d'un incendie
qui a démarré à vidauban l'autre au muy
le point avec olivier théron et raymond
chaplin vidauban 110 hectares le nuit
déjà une centaine comme en 2003 de
triste mémoire le var commence à brûler
aux premières rafales de l'été
l'autoroute des vacances est sous le
nuage rouge de l' incendie le feu
progresse notamment au niveau de la tête
ce qui a attisé par un vent extrêmement
violent extrêmement fort et le feu se
dirige dans une zone avec une ancienne
zone militarisée la part la dernière où
il ya de nombreux sont venus à saint
zacharie les cendres ne sont pas encore
froide que déjà les pompiers doivent se
mettre au travail à roquebrune
le vent est violent les volontaires sont
sur le qui vive autour des maisons
tout le monde est mobilisé pour lutter
contre les incendies positionné - une
fumée il se trouve à l'est au niveau de
valdes en garde là est ce que c'est le
feu qui se trouve sur l'île de man ou
est ce que c'est une progression autres
j'attends d'autres confirmations reçu
tout le monde se mobilise aussi contre
les pyromanes qui sème les plane depuis
le début de l'après midi
bien évidemment ces criminels on a
quatre départs de feu depuis une heure
donc en fait on a bouclé tout le secteur
avec la police municipale pour essayer
de trouver l'incendiaire parce que là
faut pas exagérer il ya des risques
d'évacuation de personnes nous n'avons
pour l'instant on évacue personnes on
prévient les cff sont sur toutes les
maisons vont arroser les toits au cas où
pour l'instant y'a pas de problème tout
est sous contrôle
les moyens aériens concentrent leurs
efforts sur les zones inaccessibles très
escarpée comme en 2003 le feu semble
vouloir aller vers la mer mais ce soir
les prévisions météo sont plutôt
optimistes
le vent devrait fléchir sensiblement
pendant la nuit il nous retrouvons
thierry clair c'était dans les bouches
du rhône en lanières manche qui a été
remporté par les pompiers ici
aujourd'hui
mais ça n'est qu'une première manche
vous constatez le vent est encore très
sévère tout autour de moi très violent
il les rafales de vent souffle à environ
100 kilomètres heure en pointe et
d'ailleurs je ne
plus la caméra à cause de la poussière
le risque d'incendié était qualifié de
très sévère par la météo aujourd'hui
pour demain la situation va sans doute
s'améliorer un peu à tous les cas elle
sera moins mauvaise car le risque latent
dit ne sera que très sévère que sévère
seulement le levant passant d'environ
100 kilomètres heure à seulement 60
demain la température va elle aussi
baissé d'une dizaine de degrés avec la
nuit qui s'approche mais les pompiers
craignent des reprises d'un syndicat
fait ces incendies ont été vous l'avions
entendu dans le reportage de virginie
tuant six qui probablement déclencher
des incendies probablement volontaire
donc cette nuit aux côtés des pompiers
vont patrouiller à la fois des gendarmes
et des polices municipales qui vont unir
leurs efforts pour tenter de lutter
contre les incendies et les incendiaires
merci thierry kurt est en phase sur le
front des incendies le feu progresse en
haute corse deux incendies qui ont
parcouru plus de 1500 hectares
les habitants des quelques villages se
sont réfugiés dans leurs maisons ou dans
des églises dorothy cochard les secours
ont demandé aux habitants de se réfugier
dans l'église de monter magueur ultime
repli aux yeux des pompiers qui ne
peuvent pas assurer une évacuation
des rafales à 100 km ferrari le travail
des canadairs et le sort s'acharne
malheureusement un problème technique
sur deux avions qui étaient trop
schilling et sur calvi ont fait que on
s'est trouvé en panne d'avion pendant
plus d'une heure les son cours perdre du
terrain possible de circonscrire le feu
les pompiers se focalise alors sur la
protection des habitations pendant un
certain temps sur ce feu là on a eu des
véhicules devant quoi on a été devant
toujours été capable de voir où ça se
passait et en même temps de m le temps
d'être réactif là maintenant concept
derrière dans la même région à qalandia
cette nuit déjà le vent redoublaient
conditions extrêmes pour des pompiers
pourtant aguerris
c'est lui et là c est très difficile
en tout 1500 hectares sont partis en
fumée
l'équivalent de deux grands
arrondissements de paris quelques
invitations aussi mais pas de victime
ce soir le ciel semble plus clément
météo france prévoit la chute du vent ce
vendredi 1er juillet donne le coup
d'envoi des grands départs avec un jour
de forte affluence dans les gares
parisiennes jusqu'à l'année la sncf
attend plus d'un million de voyageurs au
départ de la capitale
nicolas la marine et jan wald la
bicyclette les petits oiseaux
la nappe à carreaux et puis le rayon
soleil il y avait comme un avant goût de
vacances cet après midi à la gare de
lyon
cent trente mille passagers attendus ici
aujourd'hui 300 milles dans tout le week
end les clients pas stressé mais alors
personne n'a été surpris c'était écrit
dans le journal
alors les voyageurs ont été prudents ils
se sont organisés première méthode
dans les partis avec deux heures
d'avancé ces comportements
pour inquiéter plus tard
autre souci les bagages c'est lourd ça
roule mal ça prend de la place
alors ce n'est pas compliqué nos bagages
sont partis à bord faire partir ses
bagages et les récupérer à l'arrivée
la formule idéale autres services bien
utile les gilets rouges de la sncf
c'est finalement partir en vacances ce
n'est pas trop compliqué c'est juste une
question d'organisation
l'improvisation est à éviter il avait un
tgv prévue pour 17h à 26 ans n'aurait
voulu partir un petit peu avant ils sont
complets a plus place habituelle on
arrive à les échanger
aujourd'hui je crois que fait pas la
peine ce week end un million deux cent
mille voyageurs se rendront dans les
gares parisiennes pour partir en
vacances une journée orange sur les
routes annonce d'identité même drapeau
même couleur pour demain avec une
circulation en accordéon départ des
grandes villes en particulier bien sûr
vers nyon et on vallée du rhône un
dispositif renforcé pour ces grands
départs avec des opérations de contrôle
notamment gironde sur l'un des axes les
plus meurtriers de france sur l'a63 au
sud de bordeaux lever le pied la vitesse
excessive est à l'origine de la plupart
des accidents la peur du gendarme
devrait jouer francis mazier philippe
dumas il suffit de prendre un peu de
hauteur et sur cette autoroute en
direction de l'espagne
les infractions deviennent soudain plus
évidente en 2h08 poids lourds ont été
arrêtés amende de 135 euros et retrait
de points pour les chauffeurs motifs non
respect des 50 mètres la distance
minimale de sécurité
vous êtes un automobiliste vous faites
quoi effectivement quand vous êtes pris
un petit peu en un montage par de faux
lent comme ça vous n'avez même pas la
possibilité de vous de votre centre les
deux poids lourds dans ce qui est un
comportement particulièrement j'irai des
raisons de le voir irresponsables sur
l'a63 au sud de bordeaux
il y a eu 26 morts l'été dernier pour
l'opération d'aujourd'hui 250 policiers
et gendarmes ont donc été mobilisés
principale cible vitesse excessive d
alcool au volant
faites donc le ballon des contrôles
diversement appréciée y en a beaucoup
pendant les vacances maintenant assister
à une répression effréné maintenant sont
les chants les routes
c'est vrai que bon ce fait ça fait
baisser le nombre d'accidents l'été le
trafic passe de 50 à 75 8 véhicules jour
sur cet axe parmi les plus meurtriers de
france au cours du week end
les contrôles vont s'intensifier
notamment pour ce samedi classé orange
la sécurité sur les routes passe par le
respect de règles évidentes
veillez à ne pas surcharger des voitures
qui peuvent alors être déstabilisé dès
ce week-end les gendarmes vont
multiplier les contrôles sur l'a10 diego
garcia alain du bar quand vient l'été
la traque aux kilos superflus concerne
aussi les voitures et sur l'autoroute
a10 le flair des gendarmes fait
merveille
ils font mouche une fois sur deux
ces migrations saisonnières les
véhicules sont trop souvent surchargés
cela altère leur capacité de freinage et
leur tenue de route tout en faisant
chauffer les pneus nous avons l'exemple
l'été dernier d'un véhicule qui était en
surcharge de plus d'une tonne le
pneumatique éclater les véhicules se
couche sur l'autoroute un quart arrive
derrière ne donne pas l'éviter et au
résultat il ya neuf morts et plus de
cinquante trois blessés la pesée il ne
faut pas dépasser le poids total
autorisé en charge
il figure sur la carte grise cet homme
pensait déménager dans les règles
erreur c'est un véhicule qui peut
transporter 700 kg maximum 700 kg on y
arrive très rapidement donc la personne
a souhaité faire son déménagement elle
même et du coup se retrouve un pic de
tonnes de surcharge c'est vrai que je
savais pas je m'en rendrai pas du tout
contre ma part je vois pas comment
j'aurais pu faire ou j'aurais pu peser
2,90 à 1500 euros jusqu'à 3000 en cas de
récidive l'amendé elle oscille sans
compter l'immobilisation du véhicule et
le retrait de la carte grise 300 kilos
de trop cet homme a trouvé la solution
c'est de toute la famille qu'il se
déleste elle le suivra en taxi jusqu'à
la frontière espagnole
depuis ce matin les systèmes du médecin
traitant est bel et bien entré en
application un jour de rodage avec au
bout du fil le ministre en personne pour
guider ou répondre aux questions et puis
pour les malades depuis ce matin donc le
passage par le généraliste qui l'ont
choisie avant d'être orienter si besoin
vers un spécialiste reportage isabelle
quintard et arnaud juste pendant une
heure ce midi l'opératrice était un
ministre en l'occurrence celui de la
santé au bout du fil les français et
leurs questions sur le médecin traitant
d'abord se comprendre vous connaissez et
qui vous suit depuis longtemps il est à
amnéville
il est à florange j'ai tout compris
pas besoin la caméra vous aviez bertron
ainsi rassuré trois assurés sociaux sur
les 80 appels de la journée plus
concrètement dans les cabinets des
généralistes
beaucoup de patients sont venus aux
nouvelles une très bonne approche pour
reprendre des des patients qui
voyez pas du tout leurs médecins qui
sont venus uniquement pour sur le plan
administratif etc l'iran n'a pu
reprendre de certains problèmes de santé
cette patiente consulte son spécialiste
et on dépit de l'entrée en vigueur du
dispositif elle n'est pas passée par son
médecin traitant
elle préfère payer 5 euros de plus
plutôt que prendre de rendez vous
pourquoi nier que la sécu fait des
économies en faisant venir de jabra son
médecin traitant et ward spécialiste je
pense je vois pas trop l'intérêt
ça c'est pour savoir si le système va
permettre de faire des économies
il faudra encore attendre six mois
c'était aujourd'hui le premier jour et
28 millions d'assurés sociaux n'ont
toujours pas de médecin traitant les
traditionnels ot servent alors isation
du 1er juillet augmentation d'à côté
coup de pouce de l'autre le détail c'est
une juste paix
au chapitre des hausses du 1er juillet
synonyme de bonne nouvelle le smic il
augmente de 5,5 pour cent 1 million 200
mille salariés en bénéficieront les
fonctionnaires eux voient leur salaire
de base revalorisé de 0,5 pour cent
hausse également des allocations
familiales plus 1,7 pour cent pour la
location de base et la prime de
naissance plus 2,2 pour cent pour les
complément mode de garde
oublié de ces petits coups de pouce les
chômeurs ils ne verront pas leurs
indemnités revaloriser cette année pour
ce qui est des hausses qui grèvent le
porte-monnaie d'abord les tarifs du gaz
qui augmente de 4%
prendre le train sera également plus
cher le prix des billets augmentent de
façon inégale jusqu'à 2,5 pour cent pour
les corail enfin pour les franciliens du
ticket de métro à la carte orange les
tarifs ratp croiser de 1,8 pour cent en
moyenne
lot de consolation l'abonnement france
télécom le timbre et les tarifs
d'électricité eux ne bougent pas
l'unique de villepin était au havre
aujourd'hui lors d'une visite consacrée
à la lutte contre la discrimination à l
embauche des jeunes issus de
l'immigration
le premier ministre a redit son
opposition au principe de 10
élimination positive lui préférant le
principe de la promotion de l'égalité
des chances c'est d'ailleurs le titre du
ministère d'azouz begag qui
l'accompagnent enfin sachez que le
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée a déposé
une motion de censure qui sera débattue
mardi prochain juste avant le vote sur
le projet de loi permettant au
gouvernement de légiférer par ordonnance
en fait une motion de censure qui n'a
aucune chance d'être adoptée l'ump étant
largement majoritaire
côté justice le plus ancien détenu de
france condamné à la perpétuité pour
l'enlèvement et l'assassinât d'un enfant
de 11 ans lucien léger s'est vu accorder
aujourd'hui une libération
conditionnelle mais qui a été
immédiatement suspendu le parc ayant
décidé de faire appel cette affaire
s'inscrit dans un contexte particulier
avec le débat sur la récidive
amaury guibert il a passé l'essentiel de
sa vie dans cette cellule 41 ans 41 ans
de prison qui pourrait bientôt prendre
fin
lucien léger 68 ans le plus ancien
détenu de france a vu aujourd'hui sa
demande de libération conditionnelle
accepter doit être la 15e ou la 16e
et enfin cette demande est acceptée
aujourd'hui c'est donc une date
importante surtout pour lucien léger qui
peut voir enfin les portes de la prison
s'ouvrir devant lui 1er juillet 64 le
nommer léger lucien se présente à la
police
lucien léger à 27 ans lorsqu'il avoue le
meurtre du petit luc taron il reviendra
plus tard sur ses aveux mais la cour
d'assises le condamne à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
les images d'un passé dont ce boulanger
ne veut plus entendre parler
convaincue depuis toujours de
l'innocence de lucien léger il a décidé
de l'héberger à sa sortie il aura déjà
besoin de s'habituer à un rythme de vie
différent
avec beaucoup d espace autour de nuit
beaucoup de tranquillité peut-être un
peu trop mais il va s'habituer à vivre
parmi nous comme il a vécu à l'époque
mais en plein débat sur la récidive
le parquet d'arras a immédiatement fait
appel de cette décision de libération
conditionnelle
je me place du point de vue de la
protection de la société
je me place aussi j'ai une pensée pour
la victime elle aussi elle a perdu son
enfant depuis 40 ans celui qu'on
appelait à l'époque l'étrangleur
présente aujourd'hui des expertises
favorable à sa sortie d'autres juges
devront pourtant se prononcer sur son
cas dans les deux mois qui viennent
angers dans le procès pour pédophilie la
fan des réquisitions qui ont commencé
mercredi avec 20 ans de réclusion une
peine de sûreté contre l'un des
principaux accusés didier présentée par
l'avocat général
comme un prédateur sans scrupules déjà
condamné pour des agressions sexuelles
3 d'hôtes des autres accusés risquent la
perpétuité verdict vers la fin du mois
de juillet françois privat si les prix
des 30 années de réclusion au moins
requise contre eric j violeur proxénète
pervers multi récidiviste déjà condamné
en 1997 pour le viol de dix enfants
eric j est un ogre assène l'avocat
général toccanier il dévore l'innocence
des enfants font ne sait pas comment
faire donc la seule façon que l'on ait
trouvé c'est de lui est allé car c'est
l'aveu de la faiblesse de notre société
aussi face à ce problème de la
pédophilie sur un ton monocorde les
réquisitions 66 ans tous se sont
enchaînées
le parquet a demandé à plusieurs
reprises les peines maximales 20 à 30 en
aucune circonstance atténuante n'est
reconnue aux principaux accusés qui dans
la salle ont écouté sans réagir
un sentiment d'incompréhension vis-à-vis
les accusés qui n'exprime absolument
aucune réaction aucune émotion et qui
pourtant pour certains ont clamé leur
innocence ont hurlé leur innocence et
sourire à l'annoncé des réquisitions 20
ans 18 ans 15 ans on se regarde on
sourit durant ces trois jours de
réquisitoire sans concession
le parquet général a également rappelé
que ce procès avait permis de mai
en évidence l'existence d'une
prostitution enfantine organisé certes
mais en cercles familiaux ou amicaux
relativement restreint plutôt qu'au sein
d'un vaste réseau de pédophilie et puis
à perpignan les suspect interpellé
avant-hier dans l' enquête sur
l'assassinât de driss ghaib ont tous été
relâchés avant de refermer ce chapitre
sachez que quelques 200 magistrats se
sont retrouvés sur les marches du palais
de justice à paris
il s'insurge contre les propos de
nicolas sarkozy mettant en cause un juge
une manifestation pour réaffirmer le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs est
un des fondements de la démocratie fin
de citation on en vient à la sphère des
régulateurs de vitesse après plusieurs
pannes supposée sur des modèles renault
pour des experts indépendants nommés par
la justice il n'y a pas eu des
dysfonctionnements ce qui met hors de
cause deux constructeurs mais les
victimes continuent elles de douter luc
basis à la vel satis de renault et son
régulateur de vitesse sont finalement
mis hors de cause par la justice
une petite impulsion sur ce bouton et
c'est parti l'électronique prend le
relais de l'automobiliste est pourtant
un propriétaire de vel satis en octobre
dernier affirmé s'être retrouvé au
volant de sa voiture bloquée à 200
kilomètres/heure pendant 150 km sur
l'autoroute a71 après plus de huit mois
les experts de la justice conclut que
les investigations techniques et les
essais du véhicule écarte tout
dysfonctionnement du régulateur de
vitesse de quoi discréditer les
affirmations du jabra l'automobiliste
plaignants je pense pas être un
fabulateur on est plusieurs personnes
qui se promenaient arriver passé 50
minutes
risque opéré déjà de ma vie pour
commencer j'avais très intime en autre
chose à faire ce soir là que que jouer à
ce jeu là en fait le système fonctionne
grâce à une simple impulsion sur cette
manette la vitesse de croisière restent
enregistrées pour reprendre les
commandes
il suffit d'effleurer la [ __ ] de frein
40 ingénieurs de renault travaille
depuis près de neuf mois sur le
régulateur pour eux non plus la
technique n'est pas en cause
nous avons roulé des milliers de
kilomètres et la seule cause
la seule explication à laquelle nous
ayons abouti c'est une confusion dans l'
usage des pédales la machine aurait-elle
dépasser l'homme renommée maintenant en
place une cellule d'écouté pour rassurer
et conseiller ses clients
l'europe est passée depuis aujourd'hui
sous présidence britannique c'est tony
blair qui prend pour six mois les rênes
de l'union avec des dossiers brûlants
n'a tenté cette question quelle sera la
ligne que compte impulser la grande
bretagne dans une europe en crise
laurent bouvier jamais une prise de
présidence européenne n'aura été aussi
attendu autant médiatisé l'europe est en
crise alors en recevant cet après midi à
londres josé manuel barroso le président
de la commission tony blair a voulu
rassurer tous ceux que la présidence
britannique inquiète
je crois en l'europe en tant que projet
avec sa dimension sociale
l'europe n'est pas juste une zone de
libre échange un espace économique mais
cela ne sert à rien de vouloir faire du
commerce dans un monde compétitif est
difficile sans faire les changements
nécessaires rien sur la politique
agricole commune rien sur le rabais
britannique
tradition oblige quand on prend la
présidence de l'union au début en tout
cas on ne parle pas de chose qui fâche
quant au budget pomme de toutes les
discordes et cause de l'échec du dernier
sommet de bruxelles se libère a proposé
d'organiser un sommet des chefs d'état
d'ici la fin de l'année ce que veut la
grande bretagne c'est rendre l'europe
beaucoup plus ouverte sur l'extérieur
avec plus de compétition par rapport aux
marchés émergents aux etats-unis tout en
préservant une protection sociale c'est
ce que le gouvernement va essayer de
faire tout ce sommet spécial qui se
réunira ici loin de bruxelles
autrement dit le premier ministre
britannique sait que sa présidence va
être difficile et qu'il a besoin des
autres européens
en parlant de modèle social européen et
en annonçant un sommet des chefs d'états
ici à londres tony blair et c'est
visiblement de sortir l'europe d'une
crise qu'il a lui même contribué à créer
en allemagne les députés ont refusé la
confiance au chancelier gerhard schröder
suivant ainsi et sa propre volonté
puisqu'il veut provoquer des élections
anticipées en septembre pour retrouver
sa légitimité pour pouvoir poursuivre
ses réformes
à quelques jours du sommet du g8 et pour
faire pression sur les pays les plus
riches cette série d'actions qui se
veulent symbolique et spectaculaire des
monuments dans le monde entier entouré
de blanc pour mark
la solidarité nord-sud en france dans
une centre d une cinquantaine de villes
l'appel de nombreuses associations et
personnalités c'est marche blanche à
paris ou dans les jardins du trocadéro
une chaîne humaine avec de grands bancs
doublant c'est à travers le monde que se
déroulera demain une série de spectacles
présentés comme les plus grands concerts
jamais vu coup d'envoi tokyo avec sur
scène des artistes qui se mobilisent
pour l'afrique à londres paul mccartney
elton john madonna sous l'impulsion de
bob geldof à paris concert au château de
versailles derniers préparatifs
michel mompontet arnaud mickey à
edimbourg dans quatre jours les
puissants de ce monde seront réunies
donc mais plutôt comme un médecin au
chevet d'un malade le malade c'est
l'afrique bien sûr et cette misère
endémique la misère et la maladie qu'on
arriverait presque à accepter comme une
fatalité dans les banlieue de nairobi
on ne sait pas ce que g8 veut dire et
les pays riches sont inaccessibles à ses
yeux alors tout autour de la terre comme
une chaîne qui s'organise
il y a le live ait une dizaine de
concerts un dans chaque pays du g8 plus
l'afrique du sud début de la journée à
tokyo fin aux etats unis une
mobilisation transcontinental pour faire
pression sur les membres du g8
une idée de bob geldof un ancien punk
est un vrai chic type à il était
d'ailleurs l'inspirateur du live aid
pour l'ethiopie il y a vingt ans la fin
de cette journée quelque chose comme 550
millions de personnes auront vu ou
entendu quelque chose de tout ça ce sera
la plus importante action démocratique
jamais réalisé
la liste des artistes qui participeront
à ce rassemblement ressemble bottin
mondain du show-business planétaire
de new york à youssou ndour des millions
de décibels 24 heures durant
et si belle et feu d'artifice mais qui
franchiront peut-être les barrières de
sécurité de gleneagles le lieu où seront
réunis les puissants de ce monde
deux jours durant et un peu partout dans
le monde journée d'action organisée par
la coalition 2005 plus d' excuse
le but est bien à quelques jours le
disait du sommet du g8 faire pression
sur les états pour réduire l'extrême
pauvreté comme ici les manifestations à
sydney où des militants des ong portent
et un brassard blanc sous une grande
banderole proclamant pour que la
pauvreté deviennent de l'histoire
ancienne
ces manifestations se déroulent dans
d'autres pays au canada en espagne mais
aussi en inde la guerre contre la misère
et la malnutrition en afrique passe
d'abord et avant tout par l'eau a besoin
vital pour ces populations qui souffrent
de la sécheresse
voyez cet exemple au tchad et l'espoir
et dans chaque goutte d'eau une eau
comme un trésor reportage eric meunier
sylvain barral et le lever du soleil
c'est la priorité des priorités pour
chacun de ces villageois trouver les 8 à
10 litres d'eau nécessaire par jour et
par personne pour survivre dans cet
ouest tchadien aux portes du sahara
hors saison des pluies le village de ma
brio ne peut compter que sur son seul et
unique but mais encore faut-il le
partager avec deux autres hameaux des
alentours
l'eau qui en sort ne serait sous
d'autres latitudes
pas même bonne à la lessive ici elle
sert aussi à la cuisine pour la toilette
abreuver hommes et bêtes pour la ronda
nadine et ni le chef de canton le
diagnostic est sans appel c'est bien
cette eau malsaine ce puissant hygiène
qui apportent les diarrhées dont
souffrent souvent les enfants d'ici
personne n'est dupe hama brio mais y at
il d'autres choix
oui répondent mario melandri et son
équipe
voilà 15 ans que cette hydrogéologue
italien sillonnent le tchad
à lui seul il a réalisé deux mille cinq
cent des 6000 forage du pays de cette
pompe sorte une eau pure capté à 35
mètres de profondeur une eau filtrée par
les sédiments protégés par des couches
d'argile des villageois d'abuja roll ne
s'y trompe pas ici on protège les
récipients avec un couvercle et l'on se
déchausse aux abords de la pompe
abuja se croit chance onze mille euros
c'est le prix que l'union européenne
aura payé pour offrir au tchad un forage
comme celui des villageois ou cotisent
40 centimes d'euro par famille et par
mois il ne le regrette pas il y avait
ils avaient des courbatures partout et
menace leur santé s'est amélioré au
tchad
on a des régions de 3 4% se dire à 4% de
la population la population qui a accès
à l'eau et accès à l'eau potable à de
nouveaux talents en forage convoyage
équipe éric et font donc le travail
on a donné une goutte d'eau dans le
désert fernand roig had loup ne manquent
pas les moyens si l'activité sportive
c'est bien sûr le tour de france qui
commence demain évidemment lance
armstrong sera l'homme à battre jan
ullrich en a fait une obsession
et pourtant le cycliste allemand a été
victime d'un accident à l'entraînement
une très grosse frayeur nathanaël de
rincquesen sa blessure au cou est
protégé par un large pansement
malgré la douleur jan ullrich peu
rassuré ses supporteurs
cet après midi lors d'un entraînement le
coureur allemand n'a pas pu l'éviter son
véhicule de course qui freiné
brutalement
il est passé par la vitre arrière tête
la première
je suis heureux parce que les blessures
sont superficielles
les coupures du tout eu la carotide
je n'ai rien j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
j'ai aussi la tête dure si le riche va
bien l'équipe t-mobile a pris un sérieux
coup au moral
ça tombe plutôt mal le groupe sportif
allemand se présente sur le tour comme
l'outsider principal de lance armstrong
l'équipe t-mobile de jan ullrich dans
laquelle il ya nos riches mais aussi
claude anne mais aussi vinokourov est
une stratégie d'encerclement pourrait
peut-être peut-être maître absolu en
difficulté pour empêcher amstrong de
remporter un septième titre
il faut aussi compter sur la grande
forme des coureurs espagnols comme ici
roberto heras les français ne
participeront pas à la lutte pour la
victoire finale
en revanche il faudra suivre la
prestation d'ivan basso l'italien seuls
coureurs l'an passé à avoir battu
armstrong en montagne c'est sûr que le
temps ne joue pas en ma faveur j'ai 34
ans mais je suis fort et plus motivée
que jamais extrêmement décontracté ce
matin lance amstrong afficher un large
sourire
pour son dernier tour de france
l'américain veut gagner bien sûr mais il
veut surtout se faire plaisir
le compte à rebours pour les jo-2012 fin
du suspense mercredi avec un dernier
grand oral à singapour
jacques chirac et les représentants de
paris seront les premières planches et
devant les membres du cio
le maire de paris sera du voyage
l'initiateur d'un candidature était
quelques heures du départ julien moment
idem berkous sur tous les fronts à la
veille de son départ impossible pour
bertrand delanoë de ne penser qu'aux
jeux olympiques
vous êtes france 2 qui se demandaient ce
que je fais en même temps que prépare
singapour et en fer en inaugure une
inauguration qui juste avant la décision
du cio prend une tournure bien
particulière et sall maire de paris l'a
bien compris du coup son discours
s'adresse aux enfants lorsque je
demanderai au mouvement olympique
international les jeux olympiques en
2012 à paris je pense à vos regards
paris 2012
il travaille sur le dossier depuis deux
ans et demi un leitmotiv
qu'at-il à un combat à mener est en
forme et là c'est un vrai combat
et moi je trouve dopé il est bien même
quand il rencontre avec la presse
espagnole madrid est également candidate
voilà pourquoi ces journalistes sont
venus interviewer bertrand delanoë
on m'avait repris très content il est
très confiant qu'il est convaincu que
paris va gagner mais les jeux ne sont
pas faits le 6 juillet il prendra la
parole devant les membres du cio pour
une ultime intervention
je me rappelle du conseil de jean claude
killy qui m'avait dit au début bertrand
ça se jouera au centième de seconde
ça veut dire que c'est pas le moment de
se déconcentrer dernière inauguration la
place loulou gasté hauteur de 1200
chance ça font pas une île renault est
là mais il est aussi le président de la
république
voilà on se fera passer les faits c'est
du bonheur tout ça c'est l'épreuve c'est
du travail que la grèce entre à sion
c'est de la créativité collective c'est
du bonheur pour l'instant pour bertrand
delanoë c'est flash et stars du showbiz
un peu de détente avant le grand oral
cet après midi au stade de france
stéphane diagana rossi la médaille d'or
au relais 4 x 400 m les mondiaux 2003 il
ya deux ans les français étaient arrivés
deuxièmes avant que l'un des coureurs du
relais américain contrôlé positif ne
fasse disqualifier son équipe
et puis déception à wimbledon pour
amélie mauresmo la française s'est
éliminé en demi finale par l'américaine
lindsay davenport en trois sets 6-7 7-6
6-4
lindsay davenport affrontera demain en
finale sa compatriote venus williams ses
réserves
roger federer rencontrera en finale le
vainqueur de la demi-finale rodrigues
johansson vous disiez en début de
journal cette journée de vendredi marque
les premiers grands départs en vacances
en guise d'illustration les derniers
préparatifs de cette famille de ses cinq
enfants qui piaffaient d'impatience
anne-sophie schumi le comté marie cazaux
pas une minute à perdre pour cette mère
de famille dans moins de cinq heures si
le grand départ et la fin d'un marathon
ah oui ça a déjà commencé depuis hier
soir zidane je te les cours à la
poubelle et ses bras ses jambes là on
attaque ses sacs
il faut être prêt pour le dîner après le
délai ou pas c'est parti première étape
les bagages et avec cinq enfants
mieux vaut être méthodique un tour de
chaque chambre
on sort tout la pilule de ce qu'il faut
le minimum parce qu'on évite dans la
voiture et sinon ça ne tient pas on la
vend vacances et
on y va progressivement en tout sept
sacs 50 paires de chaussettes aux tons
de tee shirt sans oublier les brosses à
dents les médicaments les maillots les
serviettes les bottes et cirés le ballon
et l'appareil photo photo et des enfants
pas toujours très coopération deux fois
avec enfants deuxième étape le coffre tu
pourras mettre des chaussures quand même
content
l'exercice se révèle plutôt acrobatique
j'essaye de l'attraper la tribune a pas
le choix
tout doit tenir dans la voiture
troisième et dernière étape vérifier une
fois encore la lie cannes à pêche la
pêche seront retrouvés les jours et
précieusement ballet hockey la famille
est ce enfin prête à embarquer les
randonnées devenu le premier sport de
loisirs en france notamment l'été on
trouve de plus en plus de randonneurs
sur les sentiers les produits bien sûr
s'adapte au plus grand nombre et tout
est fait pour faciliter la vie des
marcheurs françois jullien pieds noirs
dominique bonnet la nature aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus vraiment l'aventuré finit
mal de pieds d'eau d'efforts mais
aujourd'hui tout est fait pour que le
randonneur se sentent aussi bien sur un
chemin que s'il marchait dans son jardin
avec 20 kilos sur le dos plus question
de se faire bobo au niveau du confort
portage on va faire une ceinture
pivotante qui permet de s'adapter aux
mouvements du randonneur pendant la
pratique est également avoir un dos
réglable de façon à s'adapter aux
différents types de morphologie qui
existe objectif séduire les 15 millions
de marcheurs avec un seul mot d'ordre le
confort sacs de couchage ultra compact
matelas autogonflant et même une tente
pour les feignants terminé le cauchemar
du randonneur il peut semer sa tante en
deux secondes
démonstration
elle est vrai qu'elle est très pratique
bon après transporté elle est peut-être
mans facile effectivement elle est un
peu encombrante mais fait fureur auprès
des partisans du moindre effort
mais si après l'effort c'est de partir
l'âge la journée de marché et non plus
de souffrir ou de transpirer fin de dale
t mais c'est de regarder le paysage à
droite à gauche de pouvoir discuter avec
son voisin
voilà selon là le vieillard n'y a plus
que le plaisir et le bonheur de
randonnée de se balader dans la nature
gants jetables brosse à dents le
randonneur aime aussi être propre même à
3000 m d'altitude
il aime aussi bien manger les produits
utilisés sont plus variées il y en a
pour tous les goûts
spaghettis bolognaises couscous souris
curie mais la gastronomie de randonnée
encore faut-il aimer
autre problème la bonne bouffe le robot
sait pas quant à la bonne vieille carte
vous pourrez bientôt la déchirer le
randonneur de demain crapahute rats
guidés par gps c'est moins dur et
pourtant il ya parfois tellement de
charme à se perdre dans la nature depuis
deux jours à paris le tournage du
best-seller de dan brown davinci code le
tournage a débuté dans la plus grande
discrétion dans les rôles principaux
audrey tautou et tom hanks
hier soir le quartier du louvre était
bouclé une équipe de france 2 a réussi à
surprendre quelques scènes du film le
tournage dans l'enceinte du musée
devrait se prolonger jusqu'à la fac du
mois de juillet le festival de danse de
montpellier le chorégraphe angelin
prejlocaj pour sa nouvelle création a
choisi de dépoussiérer un classique de
la musique
les quatre saisons de vivaldi abdelah
mostefa eric mézil
décors des cordes celle de vivaldi et
une question vivalis est un problème
c'est un problème aujourd'hui parce que
ça a été tellement dévoyé que c'est
insupportable dès qu'on entend un tati
tati talla d'un zip ce thème qu'est ce
qu'on va faire là dessus si possible le
jeu comment retrouver la fraîcheur d'une
musique
usé par les ascenseurs et la pub primo
choisir une version des quatre-saisons
dépouillés secundo surprendre avec un
danseur éponge deux grands bonhommes
verts des nounours en plastique une
foule d'objets un peu flou fruit de
l'imagination d'un autre artiste
ces objets qu'ils inventent qui ceux qui
n'ont pas de fonction et ont ils ont
trouvé les fonctions je pense que pour
les danseurs seldon ça donne une autre
façon de bouger nos cieux sans doute d
une autre façon de se comporter
m
brouiller les pistes en permanence
l'objectif d'angelin preljocaj basculer
du printemps à l'hiver en trouvant que
tout ça passe trop vite
douze danseurs quatre saisons un seul
message se faire plaisir
et ses fans ce journal je remercie de
votre attention tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet puis le poids route
valérie maurice 20h50 pj 1h20 le journal
de la nuit jean claude renaud et quant à
moi j'ai le plaisir de vous retrouver de
malves et 13h excellente fin de soirée
soul ans